hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers infinity
Wars introduction of Stormbreaker Thor's
new god killer battle axe is potentially
the most game-changing elements who come
to this whole Avengers saga yeah I know
sure Santa season 6 god rocks to snap
half of all life out of existence it's a
pretty big deal but think about it who
were almost stopped Thanos with storm
breaker and it didn't work but not
because Stormbreaker wasn't powerful
enough that beast cut right through the
power of all six stones combined and the
only problem was that Thor aim too low
and now concept art for infinity war was
released in a surprising amount of it
centered around Thor and his acquisition
of Stormbreaker we got a much closer
look at its whole design and originally
there's a very different process for how
it was forged so I'm gonna run through
these new details that we learned and
what they mean for the Avengers as we
wait to see Thor avenge the Fallen and
Avengers 4 hopefully after working on
his overhead axe throws boiler warning
the case I accidentally say too much
okay so infinity war Thor rocket and
teenage Groot travel to Nineveh Lear so
that the war can replace his hammer
Mjolnir which he'll are destroyed and
Ragnarok and they find Peter Dinklage as
a tree the giant dwarf who operates the
Forge but Santos had already dropped by
he wrecked the place and he forced the
tree to forge him the Infinity Gauntlet
but according to the concept art all of
this was originally going to go down
quite differently one image showed Thor
and the others in a giant cavern
discovery and Stormbreaker nestled deep
in a vine covered hole actually zoom at
it kind of looks like it's in the corpse
of a giant creature but this was a super
early version some point way later down
the line they realized it would be much
better to show Stormbreaker getting
forged here's where things start to get
really interesting the original design
for each tree was for him to have no
hands see after Thanos forced him to
forge the Infinity Gauntlet he encased
his hands in molten brew turning them
into these stumps and preventing him
from ever forging any future weapons
looks like the idea came from real human
history when architects and builders of
famous ancient structures were blinded
and mutilated by their cruel rulers so
that they could never design anything
better for anyone else in the future
history hasn't been very kind of
architects according to the concept
artists the original script simply had
the line Groot helps each read so their
conception was to have brute climb up on
a tree's back and extend his branches
forming a tree's
hands and helping them Forge the weapon
they like the idea of each tree wearing
Groot like a backpack and bantering with
each other as they complete this process
ultimately the final version of the
scene went in a different direction but
they still kept the idea of group being
part of this forging process with him
using his own branches to form the
handle of the axe and fuse the two
halves of the uru together to complete
the weapon and to answer some questions
you might have about Stormbreaker the
moment Groot severs his branch to
complete the weapon the branch is no
longer part of him so Groot would not be
able to lift the weapon like Thor can
and the handle of Stormbreaker wouldn't
have dusted away like Groot does after
Thanos to snap the concept art also
gives them much closer look at the
design of Stormbreaker
and those Asgardian runes that were
carved into the roof one of them appears
to be the word storm breaker and along
the blade of edge the phrase loose the
dogs of war now this is kind of a
well-known phrase and a reference to
William Shakespeare's play Julius Caesar
which includes a monologue in the phrase
cry havoc and let slip the dogs of war
nowadays cry havoc means for a military
commander to order soldiers to cause
chaos and pillage and destroy an area
it's kind of like release the hounds or
a Thorin of Hulk smash there's also the
back part of the battle axe with some
more Asgardian words written around the
circumference of it I'm guessing it's
something about the one weapon to rule
them all or if you can read this you've
wasted too much time learning a made-up
language but looking through all this
concept art the design of Stormbreaker
in the dozens of versions of the forge
sequence tells me that the creative team
behind this movie really wanted the
Stormbreaker weapon to come together in
a very particular way like they didn't
want this to just be a more powerful gun
that the hero achieves without paying
any price for it this is a very specific
and true Arthurian journey forth Wars
like he never Lee dies in this process
and for this to work he needs a lot of
specific pieces to come together in a
very specific way and the end result is
truly unlike anything we've seen the
Stormbreaker possesses the power of the
Bifrost allowing Thor to teleport
anywhere he wants and it appears to be
immune to the power of all six Infinity
stones that's insane and most
importantly unlike the Infinity Gauntlet
only one person can wield Stormbreaker
like if anyone gets their hand on the
Infinity Gauntlet or any of the stones
it's a
idle shift in the battle but if Thor
drops Stormbreaker it's no big deal no
one else could do anything with it at
least I soon sure vision could pick up
Mjolnir because he had an infinity stone
his head I guess but if Danis is
combined infinity stone blast couldn't
affect Stormbreaker I'm guessing
Infinity stones wouldn't make one worthy
of wielding this new weapon so my
question for you is which weapon would
you rather use in a fight the Infinity
Gauntlet or Stormbreaker comment down
below with your thoughts and follow new
rock stars on twitter and instagram at
new rockstars and for my weird inner
monologue follow me on twitter and
instant ooh live in LA area there is
another chance to see my Marvel parody
show infinity fan it's a super funny and
super torque exploration on how having
the Infinity Gauntlet might not be the
best thing and not just because an angry
Asgardian has need a better weapon but
because wish-fulfillment in general can
backfire folks with great power comes
great response to Pipitea Friday
November 16th 8:00 p.m. Acme theatre in
North Hollywood ticket info in the
description below subscribe to this
channel for more breakdowns and
everything Avengers related and Thor and
let's get to work on that axe throw